euh donc John Mark vous avez également entendu
hier qu'il est l'auteur et le développeur
de la méthode française de comptabilisation du carbone
appelée l'outil d'évaluation du carbone d'appartenance
et il est le co-fondateur de carbone pour une
société de conseil indépendante
spécialisée dans la stratégie bas carbone et l'
adaptation au changement climatique et  John
Mark poursuivra sa présentation d'
hier en approfondissant la
relation entre l'énergie et le
pouvoir économique et pourquoi il est urgent pour nous de
commencer à allouer plus de fonds pour limiter le
changement climatique maintenant merci beaucoup
je ne suis pas un économiste je pourrais aussi dire
quelques vilaines choses sur certains aspects économiques et
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec ce qui vient d'être
dit le groupe 3 du GIEC n'aurait
jamais dû être mis en place
jamais donc je vais reprendre d'où j'en
étais hier je suis désolé je n'ai pas mis  à
la bonne date et je suis désolé et je
vais généraliser ce qui vient d'être
dit et rappeler où
commence l'économie classique à partir de certains d'entre vous se souviendront peut-être
de ce type avec un num  ber de ses
collègues il y a deux siècles, il a jeté les
bases de l'économie classique en disant qu'en
fait, comme vous le savez, l'économie classique
examine quelle est la limitation du
système productif, nous nous concentrons donc sur les
deux choses qui sont les
limites de premier ordre du système de produits  et
il y a deux siècles un demi-milliard de personnes sur
terre ou de paysans les deux premières
limitations à la production sont la quantité
de terres arables qui est essentiellement du capital
et le nombre de personnes travaillant qui est du
travail et à l'époque la planète est
presque infinie par rapport à la taille  de
la population humaine et donc au premier
ordre on peut dire que toute
variation relative des ressources naturelles
peut être considérée comme non donc cet axiome
a été écrit il y a deux siècles c'est
toujours ce qu'il y a dans les
modèles économiques actuels qui ont été sophistiqués  encore
et encore sur des fondations qui sont maintenant mal
énoncées c'est comme la tour de Pise
vous
depuis le tout début ça se plie
alors ça va être  de plus en plus je
dirais déséquilibré au fur et à mesure que vous montez
donc à cause de ce qu'il avait dit nous concevons aujourd'hui l'
économie de cette manière très simple
nous avons un facteur de production qui est le
travail un autre facteur de production qui est
le capital humain et que le supermarché
est plein c'est le  comment ça marche
c'est comme ça qu'on l'enseigne encore à l'école ok
ce que je dis c'est que pour remplir le
supermarché tu ferais mieux d'avoir quelles sont les
ressources qui vont être
transformées pour remplir le supermarché et
il faut avoir la capacité de les
transformer  ressources c'est du travail
mais comme je l'ai dit hier mais je vais
mettre des chiffres derrière aujourd'hui quand tu
regardes le travail c'est la transformation
des Ressources Naturelles tu arrives avec
les chiffres que l'humanité vient pour un
quand les machines comptent pour 200 c'est à dire  l'
activité productive de notre espèce se
fait par des machines et là vous
comprenez que vous pouvez avoir deux autres
facteurs limitants sur le système le capital
n'est qu'une boucle interne dans ce sens pour
concevoir le  la première limitation que vous pouvez
avoir est sur la quantité et non sur le prix
Je me fiche du prix la quantité d'
énergie qui est la quantité qui est la
taille de la flotte de machines qui
produisent pour nous et ensuite vous aurez une
limitation sur  le PIB même si vous avez
beaucoup de travailleurs prêts à se lever le
matin et même si vous avez beaucoup d'
assouplissement quantitatif partout pour que vous
puissiez avoir 20 % du capital, ce qui sont
précisément les deux choses que nous
faisons aujourd'hui et vous pouvez le voir dans  la
forte croissance de l'OCDE ne se redresse pas
en conséquence et l'autre facteur limitant
que vous pouvez avoir est bien sûr sur les
ressources
prenons la pêche par exemple si vous
avez des gens qui peuvent investir dans des
bateaux de pêche vous avez du capital vous avez des gens des
marins qui sont prêts à  allez sur le
bateau de pêche mais vous n'avez pas de mazout pas de
pêche vous ne pouvez pas rouler vous savez sur
un bateau de pêche moderne et si vous n'avez pas de
poisson dans la mer qui apparaît gratuitement pas de
pêche ces deux éléments bien sûr
ne sont pas dans le pr  fonction oductive de la
pêche d'accord donc l'
oubli de ces deux éléments n'était pas un
problème pour le passé car quand tu
regardes le passé tu te rends compte qu'effectivement
c'était possible d'avoir de la croissance mais
justement à cause de l'énergie là tu
as une reconstruction qui est discutable
mais je  donne un ordre de grandeur du
PIB mondial depuis la naissance de m.  Jésus-
Christ, vous pouvez voir que pendant un
millénaire, la croissance n'était pas un problème
car il n'y avait pas de croissance, fondamentalement,
le parc de machines par habitant
n'augmentait pas, la taille de la
population augmentait très lentement
et vous aviez une peste de temps en temps
qui était  diminuant la taille de la
population et donc le PIB mondial
n'augmentait pas vraiment et vous vous souviendrez également
qu'à cette époque,
il n'y avait pas de démocraties. La question
que j'ai soulevée ici est de savoir si nous pourrons
maintenir les démocraties dans un monde sans
croissance parce que  comme vous le savez dans les
démocraties vous avez des élections aux
élections vous avez une compétition dans
laquelle tout le monde promet plus pour
tout le monde
vous ne dites jamais je vais donner plus à
ces gars et moins à ces gars
parfois aux très riches mais généralement
c'est plus pour tout le monde  c'est quelque chose
qui est mathématiquement impossible dans un
monde sans croissance d'accord, donc les démocraties
dans un monde sans croissance sont un problème
jusqu'à la révolution industrielle que vous avez  e
très peu de croissance et puis apparaissent des
machines et des énergies fossiles et comme vous le voyez
nous avons eu 3% pour l'éternité bien sûr nous
n'aurons pas 2% pour l'éternité et si vous
faites un zoom sur la période récente je
dirais puisque j'ai du fiable
des statistiques j'ai comploté en gros j'ai commencé à
faire quelque chose de très simple il y a dix
ans c'était de tracer le PIB mondial bien sûr
en argent constant par rapport à la
consommation mondiale d'énergie quelle est la
consommation mondiale d'énergie c'est le
parc mondial de machines qui est  ce que c'est donc
ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est que le PIB mondial
est une fonction linéaire une fonction linéaire
de la taille du parc mondial de
machines point complet c'est aussi simple que
cela donc le meilleur modèle macroéconomique
que je connaisse est une ligne droite et il
dit qu'en fait le premier
facteur limitant du PIB mondial est la consommation mondiale d'
énergie qui est aujourd'hui le
premier
facteur limitant en fait nous avons un excès
de travail il y a du chômage partout
nous avons un excès de capital nous avons
une bulle spéculative  s et beaucoup d'argent
qu'on ne peut pas investir partout donc
aujourd'hui le premier facteur limitant c'est l'
énergie et pour être encore plus précis vous
verrez que le premier facteur limitant
c'est le pétrole donc parce que la
Révolution Industrielle allait justement partir des
énergies renouvelables qui en alimentaient une
centaine  cent de l'énergie mondiale il y a deux
ou trois siècles aux combustibles fossiles
et nous ne l'avons pas fait parce que nous étions
stupides nous l'avons fait parce que la densité
de combustible fossile du contenu énergétique des
combustibles fossiles est incomparable par rapport aux
énergies renouvelables les combustibles fossiles sont les
un seul que vous pouvez transporter avec vous
partout que vous pouvez utiliser quand vous
voulez et où vous voulez et qui
permet de mettre en mouvement ce
costume d'Iron Man que nous avons fabriqué pour
nous tous ok et parce qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les
énergies fossiles qui constituent l'essentiel  de
l'approvisionnement énergétique dans le monde, vous avez également
cette relation quasi linéaire
entre le PIB mondial et le co2, donc cela se
rapporte à ce que j'ai dit oui  Aujourd'hui, il
n'y a absolument aucun moyen de lutter
contre le changement climatique avec le bon ordre de
grandeur qui divise les
émissions mondiales par 3 en 30 ans sans
déclencher une récession mondiale, il n'y a
absolument aucun moyen de le faire physiquement,
alors aujourd'hui, nous disons que nous sommes sérieux
et le changement climatique et que nous aurons de la
croissance, je suis désolé de le dire à cette
jeune femme absolument charmante mais c'est
un gros gros mensonge ce n'est pas quelque chose que je suis
prêt à parier toutes mes économies avec
tous ceux qui souhaitent dans la salle que nous
allons  n'y arriverons jamais
donc nous donc c'est le drame des pourparlers sur le
climat c'est le drame du
comateux aujourd'hui plutôt nous sommes à la
croisée des chemins il faut choisir soit on
veut la stabilité sur le long terme et
puis il faut contracter le
système productif  ou nous disons profitons de
ce système productif tant qu'il
fonctionne mais il ne fonctionnera pas
pour l'éternité et alors les
conséquences seront quelles qu'elles soient
et en fait à cause du décalage temporel
que nous avons entre les émissions et les
conséquences que j'évoquais hier,
il y aura un moment de l'histoire où
nous aurons de moins en moins d'énergie à cause
de l'épuisement des combustibles fossiles qui est de moins
en moins un moyen d'affronter l'adversité et une
adversité croissante à cause de l'inertie
des  le changement climatique cela va être une
très belle situation et je doute que cela
nuise au PIB pour moins de 3% je
pense que vous pouvez ajouter deux zéros à cela ce que
vous pouvez voir sur ce graphique est aussi que
non seulement vous avez un  réponse linéaire en
chiffres absolus mais en fait vous avez aussi
une très bonne réponse quand vous
regardez l'évolution annuelle sur ces deux graphiques
sur ces deux courbes la courbe verte
vous donne l'évolution annuelle l'année sur
votre évolution de l'approvisionnement énergétique dans le
monde le  consommation d'énergie dans le
monde, c'est donc à nouveau le
parc de machines en fonctionnement dans le monde, c'est donc
le changement annuel de la taille du
parc de machines en fonctionnement dans
le monde et la ligne bleue vous donne
e  e année sur votre changement du PIB mondial
et donc ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est qu'il y a
parfaitement les deux pieds et quand ils
ne le font pas, il y a généralement une correction
assez peu de temps après et en fait cet
ajustement est encore meilleur pour le pétrole, donc ici
vous voyez  deux courbes à nouveau la rouge
vous donne en fait ce n'est pas un an
sur votre changement c'est une moyenne glissante sur trois ans
mais c'est exactement la même chose en ce qui concerne
la production de pétrole et c'est la production de pétrole
en volumes en volume désolé donc c'est la
quantité de tonnes nombre de tonnes  de pétrole
que vous extrayez du sol chaque
année et c'est en fait la variation et
la ligne bleue représente le PIB par
habitant la variation de l'année sur votre
variation du PIB par habitant
dans le monde et ce que vous pouvez voir sur
ce graphique c'est que nous  n'avons pas un PIB
qui augmente parce qu'il vient de
Mars et ensuite nous utilisons plus de pétrole parce que nous
pouvons l'acheter ce que vous pouvez voir, c'est que
la variation rouge se produit un peu
avant la bleue, ce qui signifie que d'
abord nous extr  agissons plus de pétrole du
sol alors nous faisons fonctionner plus de machines et
ensuite nous aurons plus de production et
ensuite nous comptons cette production avec des
dollars et elle augmente et le fait
que les deux courbes s'adaptent parfaitement après
le choc pétrolier signifie que depuis les
chocs pétroliers le pétrole a  été la première limite, il
est devenu le premier facteur limitant de la
production de pétrole,
donc aujourd'hui, si vous voulez des
prévisions fiables sur ce que sera le PIB
dans les années à venir, tout ce dont vous avez besoin, ce sont
des prévisions fiables sur la production de pétrole
dans les années à  venez c'est tout ce dont vous avez
besoin
j'ai commencé ce travail il y a 10 ans il a fait des
merveilles concernant mes anciennes prédictions
depuis alors oubliez les les
modèles économiques qu'ils viennent vous dire ça et
la raison pour laquelle je vais généraliser
ce qui vient d'être dit par  mon
distingué voisin est parce que je vais
revenir sur ce que je viens de dire
hier et le reformuler d'une
manière différente La
nature nous a redonné
gratuitement des énergies fossiles donc gratuitement
personne dans cette salle n'a payé  un seul centime
pour les combustibles fossiles pour former ce que nous payons en
matière d'énergie est toujours la même
chose ce sont des revenus humains correspondant
au fait que nous allons chercher l'
énergie qui est ici gratuitement et ces
revenus humains sont à la fois du travail doivent
payer les gens dans  total kumbaya et ainsi
de suite et les gens qui s'assoient sur les
champs pour lesquels soit vous les payez, soit
vous les écrasez en fonction de l'époque
de l'histoire ce que le Moyen-Orient a été
conçu de cette façon nous venons juste de dire que
nous allons concevoir  les choses de cette façon
c'est pourquoi les frontières sont toutes droites
parce que fondamentalement c'est ainsi que nous
avons un
partage organisé du pétrole afin que les combustibles fossiles soient gratuits
comme je dis la combustion qu'ils ont permis de
transformer tout le reste et tout le reste
nous a donné le socio  structure socio-économique
que nous avons conçue dans
les pays occidentaux en raison du parc
de machines nous accordant une énorme
productivité de travail nous avons beaucoup de
temps libre qui nous permet d'effectuer de longues
études la retraite  semaine et jours fériés
travaillant seulement 35 heures par semaine en France
etc tout cela est le résultat de l'énergie tout
cela est le résultat de l'énergie donc la
façon dont nous avons concentré les gens dans les
villes parce que nous n'avons pas besoin de gens à
la campagne parce que nous avons
c'est aussi le résultat de l'énergie, donc l'
énergie est fondamentalement ce qui a conçu
le monde moderne et le PIB ne compte que
ce n'est plus le cas et j'insiste sur le fait qu'un actif Le PIB
est un flux annuel ce n'est pas un actif
c'est un flux IRA vous ne devenez pas plus riche
parce que  le PIB augmente si vos
revenus augmentent et que vous jouez
au casino augmente plus vite vous ne
devenez pas plus riche d'accord vous ne devenez pas plus riche
seulement nous avons créé une façon de considérer l'
économie où nous n'avons que des revenus et
pas de dépenses le PIB est un système  sans
dépenses d'accord et nous avons au moins deux
goulots d'étranglement en fait vous en avez plus mais
deux goulots d'étranglement dans le système le
premier est le changement climatique le second sur
lequel je pense que vous devriez faire un
peu plus attention que wh  ce
qui se fait actuellement dans la presse occidentale c'est
le goulot d'étranglement en amont qu'est l'
approvisionnement en énergies fossiles qui sait dans cette
salle que le conventionnel ou une production a
culminé en 2008 tous les autres devraient le
savoir tous les autres devraient le savoir y
compris le pétrole non conventionnel
la production dans le monde est restée
stable depuis 2005, le seul donc aujourd'hui le
producteur de swing n'est plus l'Arabie saoudite,
c'est du pétrole de schiste aux états-unis.  qui le
sait depuis une petite minorité dans la
salle,
donc le pétrole de schiste diminue, ce qui
arrivera un jour, notre production dans le
monde diminue et parce que je viens de
montrer avant que l'économie mondiale ne s'effondre,
alors redescend en fait, donc
c'est  la façon dont ce que Meadows a fait
il y a 40 ans était précisément de concevoir
une pensée économique sur la base de
ce qui se passe physiquement dans le monde,
c'est précisément ce qui l'a fait et le
résultat très désagréable auquel il est arrivé était
qu'il y aurait un maximum absolu
au  PIB quelque chose que les
économies classiques ont échappé à la façon dont elles ont
conçu l'économie afin qu'elles puissent garder le
cap sur cette illusion que nous avons
comme un week-end que nous regrettons de pouvoir avoir
une croissance perpétuelle, mais encore une fois c'est un
conte de fées et de généraliser ce qui
vient d'être dit auparavant  aujourd'hui comme les
ressources naturelles sont gratuites cela n'a pas de prix et
je partage entièrement la conclusion que le
prix Nobel de noter maison est un canular c'est
une blague c'est une grosse blague si vous ne le faites pas
avoir n'importe quel prix pour les actifs naturels le
prix de la planète Terre est maintenant nul
comment pouvez-vous concevoir une fonction de dommage sur
un actif qui vaut zéro c'est le
seul moyen c'est le seul moyen et même les
seigneurs se tournent pour lesquels j'ai un très
profond respect quand  il a dit que le
changement climatique pourrait nuire au PIB jusqu'à six
pour cent, il aurait pu dire soixante-quinze
ou trois la même chose, je veux dire dans tous les cas
comme celui-ci, car encore une fois, vous ne pouvez pas
concevoir autrement une fonction de dommage
sur un actif qui, par définition, par axiome
a un  valeur qui est zéro vous ne pouvez tout simplement
pas et vous pouvez avoir
des fonctions très sophistiquées après l'
hypothèse stupide vous aurez un résultat stupide d'
accord et les gens confondent la complexité
du modèle et le fait que le modèle est
pertinent mais il est très facile de concevoir un modèle
très complexe  modèle stupide je peux faire ça
tous les jours échouer si je veux
[Applaudissements]